weissach nicht eine sache gibt es dann
noch die man die ihr vielleicht noch
nicht wissen aber ich weiß nicht ob ich
die sagen da q-cells kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute werde ich euch mal alles zum thema
burger battle berichten und euch die
ganze geschichte erzählen was da jetzt
eigentlich passiert ist in letzter zeit
relativ viel mitbekommen davon auf einem
kanal
aber wie ist jetzt eigentlich
ausgegangen dass werdet ihr im heutigen
video erleben erzählt bekommen und ich
werde euch sozusagen sagen sozusagen
sagen wow das biotop von construction du
stirbst dafür bitter es ist sehr gut
dass straif also es ging erstmal es geht
erstmal solos leute das kann ich jetzt
schon mal sagen das wort hin ging
gestern abend um 24 uhr zu ende und wir
haben es gewonnen
wir haben tatsächlich geschaffen dass er
sagt dass er da kommt nicht mehr raus
jetzt muss das sterben ok alles klar
wir haben das voting gewonnen und dafür
möchte ich allen die gibt allen die
gewartet haben möchte ich echt ganz von
ganzem herzen danke schön sagen danke
für die unterstützung
es ist zwar sei jetzt nur ein voting
oder so aber ich fand es echt krass dass
so viele leute mich unterstützt haben
und auch so richtig viele youtuber als
es ein echt eng wurde kamen dann erweist
justin veni doktor banks kabel logo so
viele youtube mit denen ich jetzt
teilweise nicht mal so super intensiv
kontakt habt kamen dann einfach und
haben sich zwar bereit erklärten mir
dazu helfen
ganz uneigennützig ohne dass sie dafür
irgendwas bekommen würden und das war
einfach stark
er will aber auf mich aber ich will dich
dass du bist weg hier
der boden empor berlin so mit mir dann
alles klar
es war einfach wichtig also da freut man
sich einfach drüber alles klar ps ab
werk sehr schön
ein helm vielleicht ein helm haben wir
hier gut also ich nochmal an alle die da
unterstützt haben und auch an jeden
einzelnen zuschauer zuschauer von
anderen leuten sonstige menschen drauf
gekommen sind über tritsch instagram
danke danke danke für jede einzelne wort
es war wirklich wirklich cool und es
wird einfach richtig geil dieses
wochenende wird so cool ich erzähle ich
mal ein bisschen was wie das jetzt läuft
am freitagabend werde ich nach münchen
fahren
da treffe ich dann abends lukas verweis
und werden mit dem ein bisschen was
starten bayern münchen macht irgendwas
cooles dann am samstagmorgen geht es
weiter dann habe ich dann die
gelegenheit meinen eigenen bürger zu zu
bauen selbst zu kochen und einer jury zu
präsentieren und in der jury sitzen auch
noch youtuber ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
das ich glaube es wird auf instagram
schon release das kgb dabei sein wird
hat sie glaube ich auf ihrem instagram
account schon gesagt dass sie dabei sein
wird
da kommt einer absage alles klar
so erfrischt die ganze teile
ja ok aber das wird das wird knapp es
gibt oft gut sehr schön erwischt sehr
schön da gebietet auch deine juli dabei
sein da kommt der nächste
kurz mal ein bisschen tnt in bremse
gedrückt
meisterfeier hinterher
und ja ich weiß nicht ist wird glaube
ich auch ein zweiter youtuber natürlich
jetzt nicht weiß aber nicht genau wer
das ist
also ich bin ja selbst auch gespannt und
ich dachte mein burger bauen der jury
präsentieren und die entscheidet dann
wer weiter kommt und die leute die
weiterkommen also die vier die aus
diesen 16 weiterkommen die haben dann
die gelegenheit dass ihr burger ich
glaube in mehreren restaurants in
baumärkten angeboten würde ich
vielleicht sogar bundesweit ich weiß es
nicht ich glaube bei den letzten malen
burger battle war es so dass ist dann
ein burger für eine woche für eine woche
gab also immer für eine woche die bürger
ihnen bürger für eine woche nacheinander
so war das glaube ich auch nicht
schlecht
hier in die luft jetzt gibt kommt ja ja
ja ja ist download ist anke barth ich
bin live auf fahrten mit zwei herzen
richtig derweil da wird er war nicht
schlecht es gut gemacht märz gut gemacht
wie es gipfelt direkt zunächst ronald
koeman ich auch so machen events wie sie
entspannt und ohne kategorie back bisher
gerade special vor am samstag wird es
dann so sein
übrigens am samstag werde mich auch zwei
freunde besuchen die unterstützen mich
da die familie zusammen dahin und max
wird auch kommen der fährt auf runter
nach münchen und besucht mich nach und
dann habe ich meine unterstützer im
rücken und kann man mein burger da
präsentieren ich werde erst 60 sekündige
präsentationen halten und dann in einem
zweiten schritt kommt man den bürgern
jury bewertete man tritt er im eins
gegen eins an gegen anderen gegner und
ich hoffe dass ich halt nicht gegen rw
antreten muss stellt euch mal vor wie
blöd das wäre wenn ich den gegenbeweis
antreten müsste und vielleicht erweist
dann raus obwohl er ist halt ab mit es
ermöglicht hat er sich überhaupt da
hinfahren davor der mich ja auch
unterstützt hat mit twitter posten
aufrufen zu unterstützen hat echt übel
ich hoffe dass es nicht so kommen ich
hoffe dass ich nicht gegen lukas
antreten muss sonst muss mir etwas
überlegen schon sehr sehr harter
gewissenskonflikt aber leute ich ihr
wisst gar nicht wie kuli sache ist aber
ich freue mich einfach richtig das
machen zu können
das ist so cool organisiert alles ist
jetzt keine schleichwerbung ich find's
einfach so witzig was das mandat mainka
kommt halt freitagabend hindern wird man
da irgendwo untergebracht und sodann am
nächsten morgen fährt man dann in
betriebnahme wieder bei youtube und so
also mir macht es einfach richtig spaß
ich freue mich darauf und stellt
wahrscheinlich
ok jetzt muss erst mal auf und jetzt
muss ich jetzt jetzt habe man läuft auch
auf dem bogen einen bogen meine ich
natürlich es ist wirklich eine gute
sache und dann samstag geht das damit
bis 17 uhr oder so und dann geht es dann
für mich wieder nach hause und dann nach
hause la familia bei maxxim ich hab in
münchen besucht ich pack's in mein auto
eine wir fahren nach hause
das wird so wirtgen ja ich freue mich
richtig auf die kommenden tage sehr sehr
sehr geil und das alles nur danke euch
möglich also ich mache mir da wirklich
eine große freude
das wollte ich nur mal gesagt haben ja
falls sie doch irgendwelche fragen zu
diesem event habt dann schreibt die
gerne unten die kommentare rein da werde
ich doch mal rein schon wenn das video
dann online ist ohne es für euch
beantworten weil ich mich derweil damit
beschäftigt habe
ich weiß auch nicht eine sache gibt es
da noch die man die ihr vielleicht noch
nicht wissen aber ich weiß ihr mich die
sagen darf ich weiß es nicht auf die
verraten darf mir wurde schon mitgeteilt
haben jetzt eine kleine gruppe
aufgemacht
für das burger event also lukas job
macht und ich und mitschreiben ganz
tolle sache und sprechen den shadow of
the weather com
nein nein mit der ami holt er hat mich
erholt oder [ __ ] ja leute heute war
nicht so krass kirche vor die erste
runde ganz gut war am ende hatten den
heftigen gegner war in ordnung würde ich
sagen es geht mir darum euch das erzählt
zu haben und das video noch rechtzeitig
online zu bringen
denn es ist schon wieder so spät also
lasst gerne daumen nach oben darstellt
fragen falls ich noch nicht beantwortet
habe wir sind nicht so wie du wieder
haut rein macht's gut und ich sprechen